good morning I'm Norah O'Donnell with
John Dickerson and Gayle King President
Trump tweeted again this morning
disputing a quote of him using vulgar
words in the immigration debate he wrote
on Twitter quote the language used by me
at the daka meeting was tough but this
was not the language used what was
really tough was the outlandish proposal
made a big setback for daca the
president is apparently referring to an
idea spelled out by Democratic Senator
Dick Durbin about protection for
immigrants from Haiti El Salvador and
several African countries one person
briefed on the meeting tells CBS News
the president responded why do we want
all these people from these expletive
hole countries here we should bring in
more people from places like Norway now
lawmakers quickly condemned that
language Republican senator Tim Scott
said our strength lies in our diversity
including those who came here from
Africa the Caribbean in every other
corner of the world to deny these facts
would be to ignore the brightest the
brightest rather part of our history
Republican congresswoman Mia love says
this her parents are from Haiti she said
the comments were unkind divisive
elitist and fly in the face of our
nation's values